er wurde schon wollen dass mich immer
passiert ist eigentlich einfach raus
genommen wurde
die titel des videos welt hey was geht
ab jetzt bekommen bayern mein video
ich bin grad noch alleine gleich kommt
allerdings wieder der herr izmir und
unser letzter prank oder dass ich ihn
geprägt habe das ist schon so zwei
wochen her ich hab mir gedacht es ist
wieder an der zeit
mir ist schon so vor eineinhalb wochen
aus geiles eingefallen aber ich habe mir
gedacht du musst noch zeit lassen weil
sonst fällt das vielleicht auf oder kann
auffallen
ja wir sind ja beide im gleichen
netzwerk und ich kann auch sein partner
manager oder halt der dort für ihn
zuständig ist kann ich auch ganz gut und
ich hab halt schon mit ihm so absprache
geeinigt ruft das gleich an und sag
inhalt er soll sein bestes video wartet
ich zeige euch das mal kurz das ding ist
halt herz sagt mir wirklich so mal so
auch sein bestes video geht immer noch
ab das hat schon so über 800.000 es
wirklich so voll stolz auf dieses video
weil es auch schon ziemlich viele
gesehen haben das kenne ich auch zu gut
dieses gefühl war dadurch zeigt richters
kurz das video hat 845.000 views
freundin bringt mich zurück geht schief
also keine ahnung und genau dieses video
wird halt als partnermanager der hat
halt die daten so das gehört halt dazu
das ist halt so wird da auch privat
stellen
und wenn herauskommt dann dann spiele
ich ihnen oder sagt ein bisschen york
man ein video oder wir gucken uns das
zusammen also lasst zeit man viel kriegs
blabla weiß ich nicht aber das wenige
was einfallen
und dann wird er sehen dass videos weg
mal sehen wie er reagiert hiess alex wir
haben ja letzte woche
gesprochen wir wollten ja diesen gesagt
wegen herz hast du hast zwei minuten
oder so also herauskommt also das wird
halt perfekt passen wenn du das jetzt
schnell machen würdest ich weiß nicht ob
du das direkt machen kann oder ob das
bisschen dauert also einfach nur kurz
einloggen und dann du kannst ja dieses
wie du meinst ja das hat auch keine
schlechten auswirkungen mal so dann auf
wenn es einmal privat also wenn man es
einmal privat stellt und dann wir online
stellt nicht das dann nachher nicht mehr
gepflegt wird also das wäre auch scheiße
aber das geht klar dass hier klar also
dass ist diese das wäre dieses video
seien meist geklickte das muss einfach
gucken dieses freundin bringt mich über
so ok cool wie lange dauert es ungefähr
wissen kannst kannst mir einfach bei uns
kannst du mir so ich gleich machen ok
kannst mir beim schreiben wendet wenn es
alle offline gestellt hat dank und grüße
von mir ne yo ich bin ich doch auch mein
köln übrigens man sieht schon alles klar
sein kann diese kamera in cannes die an
machen weil ich keinen bock drauf das
mal so hin und her zu schneiden aber wir
machen auch an also die lehrer liegt auf
meinem tui dass ich nicht mehr brauche
die kamera steht hier so dass geiles
teil bei der kamera man kann das
umklappen und das fällt nicht auf das
sie aufnimmt so außer hier links wohl
aber nicht mehr verraten award bekommen
das müsste jetzt schon online seite
offline sollen deswegen schnell dann
warten wir jetzt einfach noch kurz er
müsste das ding ist halt immer bei denen
das regt mich so auf der sagt er kommt
zehn minuten aber das tor dann in eine
stunde ohne winzer heute schon
wir haben jetzt 18 35 und der wolf schon
17 uhr hier sein
so ist das
antworten videos nicht wir müssen also
jetzt könnt ihr könnte mich das noch
machen oder nicht
und deiner filmerin leider habe die ich
habe eigentlich ein bisschen aufgepasst
ich gehe ich dahin rundlicher sollen ja
irgendwie oder so abgegangen letzte
deiner freundin gesehen wie man das
große erfolg als auch mit seiner
freundin explodiert 1850
das läuft also ich finde es mir deine
freundin rein und es geht direkt ab so
obwohl das video so zum beispiel bei
manche videos nicht ohne witz bei den
highlights bei dem meine freundin und
ich hab es ein zwei stunden war das
fertig nicht mal das gerne beliebteste
video von mir
beliebt sind
körper das sind hier die größte
beliebtheit kann auch mal verliehen
irgendwie wurde schon mal das mikro
passiert ist eigentlich einfach raus
genommen wurde
die ist ein wo ich im auto gefahren will
der firma die als mächtiger das video
sehen was man isst oder auch gelöscht
hatte es mir aber zügig wieder geholt
was der konsens trocken als wenn du dir
als lassen er wurde youtube irgendwie
anrufen kontaktiert von youtube hier
habe ich ganz eigentlich 0 180 5
46 ich sag jetzt macht es wieder nähert
sich auf der linken seite richten sind
aber ich glaube daran warum
klick klick öffnet aber hier liegt das
was mit dem video wand gefallen was nach
oben herab könnt ihr essen bis zum
nächsten tag muss ich mir wahrscheinlich
wieder zeit jedes mal nicht in kommunen
wie den reben in ruhe das nächste mal
ein gefühl das ist wenn du dich so
kraftvoll sind hoch sind wie viele
klicks dein video erreicht bis zu einer
million videos zweck bei mir so leid mir
wurde schon mal ein video einfach
weggenommen und an alle die mal sagen
verhältnis gebracht ohne chance
betrachten jetzt kommen wahrscheinlich
wieder die leute raus mit euch mal reden
lässigkeit deutsch alter ist es reicht
also abonniert hat ganz oben in der
video beschreibung verlinkt sonntag
kommen 300.000 special würd mich freuen
wenn das update 14 uhr drei leute hieß